sie haben gewonnen 100 millionen euro im
jackpot toll oder nein tatsächlich hätte
ihn kaum was schlimmeres passieren
können bestimmt hast du auch schon mal
von leuten gehört die ihre großen
gewinne vom lotto innerhalb von
kürzester zeit verspielt verschwendet
oder verloren haben leider stehen die
chancen gar nicht schlecht dass dir
genau das gleiche passieren würde
eine studie des harvard college es hat
herausgefunden je mehr geld du motto
gewinnst desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass zur nächsten
drei bis fünf jahren pleite ist ist doch
eigentlich paradox oder die wenigsten
menschen gehen im alltag pleite aber
sobald jemand viel geld bekommt steigen
die chancen dafür extrem
vielleicht liegt es an den leuten die
lotto spielen klar
glücksspieler sind vielleicht nicht die
verantwortungsvollsten menschen wenn es
um geld geht
vielleicht geht es hier aber auch um
geld und gier an sich denn viel geld
zieht immer auch die aufmerksamkeit von
vielen neidischen blicken auf sich was
solltest du also tun falls du wirklich
einmal das pech haben solltest im lotto
zu gewinnen
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
aufgewachsen und vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren und kein neues video
zu verpassen
wir vor
service
the whole story 2002 hat der
us-amerikaner jacob picard den damals
größten jackpot der us geschichte
gewonnen
315 millionen dollar schon vor dem
gewinn politiker eigentlich finanziell
sehr gut aufgestellt er hatte eine
erfolgreiche firma war verheiratet hatte
kinder und enkelkinder
das heißt er konnte mit geld umgehen und
hatte leute um sich herum denen er
vertraut hat und so lebt er glücklich
bis an sein lebensende
naja nicht wirklich denn nachdem sich
politiker seinen riesigen lotto gewinn
hat auszahlen lassen ging alles ganz
schnell bergab
da er seinen gewinn öffentlich entgegen
genommen hat wurde er von stalkern
leuten mit kuriosen geschäftsideen oder
alten freunden die dringend geld
brauchten regelrecht belagert er stellte
allein drei leute an um seine passt zu
sortieren
doch die leute klingelten bald bei ihnen
zu hause so war er gezwungen
sicherheitsleute zu bezahlen um seine
familie zu beschützen
danach verkehrspolitiker mehr und mehr
in örtlichen stripclubs einen teil
seines gewinns hatte er immer weise
so wurde ein jahr später in sein auto
eingebrochen hierbei erbeuteten diebe
knapp 550.000 dollar
auf die frage hin warum er so viel geld
mit in den stripclub nehmen würde
antwortete er nur weil ich es kann
kurz darauf wurden zwei mitarbeiter des
clubs verhaftet als sie versucht haben
mutig zu vergiften nur ein jahr später
wurden durch einen zweiten einbruch
weitere 200.000 dollar erbeutet zu
dieser zeit hatte kai sein geld noch
schlauer angelegt seine firma hat sich
verdoppelt und er spendete 14 millionen
dollar für wohltätige zwecke
trotzdem nahmen tragische ereignisse
ihren lauf seine familie und menschen in
seinem umfeld wurden opfer von mehreren
drogen und fehlen dann ist auch noch
seine tochter gestorben kurz danach hat
sich seine frau von ihm getrennt
heute ist mutiger bankrott und schwer
verschuldet das ist wirklich eine
tragische geschichte
aber vielleicht hatte multicar einfach
nur pech oder sich ein bisschen blöd
angestellt
duda ich wir würden natürlich viel
schlauer mit unseren gewinn umgehen oder
und zwar ist es ja auch nur ein beispiel
richtig falsch billy bob herald junior
gewannen 1997 31 millionen dollar
nur zwei jahre später nahm harrell sich
das leben nach endlosen battle 1 durch
freunde und familie die lotterie zu
gewinnen ist das schlimmste was mir
jemals passiert ist soll er noch gesagt
haben
william post hat 1988 16 millionen
dollar gewonnen ein jahr später
beauftragte seinen bruder einen
auftragsmörder um ihn und seine frau zu
töten und so ans erbe heranzukommen
er kam zwar mit dem leben davon ging
aber später bankrott und landete im
gefängnis nachdem er auf einen
schuldeneintreiber geschossen hatte 1996
gewann jeffrey tampa 20 millionen dollar
zehn jahre später wurde er von seiner
schwägerin und ihrem mann entführt und
ermordet und das ist nur ein kleiner
teil der schicksale vieler lottogewinner
was uns endlich zu der großen frage
bringt was solltest du tun falls du
einmal das pech haben sollte ist im
lotto zu gewinnen
und die überraschende antwort lautet
erst einmal gar nichts
dein größter feind im falle eines
gewinns bist du selber direkt am ersten
tag deinen job kündigen ein teures auto
bestellen und den gewinn auf facebook
posten ist wahrscheinlich keine gute
idee nicht einmal deiner familie und
einen engeren freunden solltest du es
erzählen
zumindest noch nicht als erstes suchst
du dir am besten einen neuen anwalt
nicht eure nördlichen familienanwalt der
dir geholfen hat das geld für deinen
geklautes fahrrad zurück zu bekommen
in einen am besten jemanden die nur noch
nie gesehen hast und jemand der
niemanden aus deinem umfeld kennt am
besten fährt in die nächste großstadt
und suchst dir dort eine der top
kanzleien des landes raus wie kannst du
dir jetzt nämlich leisten zusammen mit
einem teuren spitzen anwalt solltest du
genau festlegen wie viel du an deine
familie und freunde verschenken willst
vielleicht so um die 20 prozent das
wären an unseren einfachen
rechenbeispiel 20 millionen euro und
sollte höchstwahrscheinlich reichen um
deine liebsten abzusichern
so musst du dich nicht mit der frage
auseinandersetzen ob du deinem onkel
jürgen 20.000 euro für den start seines
aquarium fachhandels oder was auch immer
schenken möchtest du hast vorher
festgelegt wie viel du jürgen gibst was
er damit macht ist seine sache
du bist also fein aus dem schneider noch
weiß du aber keine in einer familie in
diese schritte ein
die auszahlung übernimmt später dann
neuer anwalt sobald das geschafft ist
triffst du auf deinen schlimmsten
widersacher dich selber eine große menge
geld kann sicherheit und unabhängigkeit
für den rest deines lebens bedeuten aber
du wirst in den nächsten monaten
erfahren dass man geld sehr schnell
ausgeben kann
was ist schon hier und da eine millionen
wenn man noch 80 millionen hat du musst
dir also ein sicherheitsnetz aufbauen
zahl am besten weitere 20 prozent seines
gewinns direkt ein und riegel
vertraglich dass du nur in
notsituationen und immer nur auf einen
teil dieses geldes zu greifen kannst das
sorgt dafür dass du da nicht einfach so
rein kommst dieses geld ist nicht zum
verprassen auch nicht zum investieren
oder verschenken
das ist eine altersvorsorge 50 prozent
der summe lässt du für dich investieren
und anlegen sein anwalt wirklich
vermitteln können und auch aufpassen
dass du hier nicht über den tisch
gezogen wird
die profis sollen ein vermögen möglichst
sicher breit und langfristig für dich
anlegen denn selbst bei schlechten
zinsen wirst du jährlich genug geld
erwirtschaften um
mehr als locker über die runden zu
kommen mit jährlichen zinsen von 4
prozent würdest du zb jeden monat 100
66.000 euro bekommen klar darauf muss
man dann noch steuern zahlen aber dieses
geld bekommst du jeden monat für den
rest deines lebens und dann eigentliches
vermögen wird dabei nicht weniger weil
die ja von den zinsen lebst jetzt wo du
dich um freunde und familie ein
monatliches einkommen und eine
altersvorsorge für notfälle gekümmert
hast wird es endlich zeit seinen gewinn
auch entgegenzunehmen und wenn du hier
nicht höllisch aufpasst dann kannst du
ein riesiges problem bekommen
in der gesamten eu kann man gewinne
anonym annehmen nimmt von diesem recht
auf jeden fall gebraucht das kann ich
nicht deutlich genug sagen in china zum
beispiel muss man die gewinne öffentlich
und persönlich abholen was dafür gesorgt
hat dass kostüme wie diese hier ganz
normal sind das letzte was man mit
seinem vermögen tun sollte ist jedem zu
erzählen dass man es habe deswegen ist
es auch so wichtig dass erst einmal
niemand etwas von einem gewinn war es
und das führt mich zu meinem letzten und
vielleicht wichtigsten ratschlag warte
ein ganzes jahr ab bis du irgendetwas
davon in die tat umsetzt das hat mehrere
gründe zum einen wird trotz des gesetzes
dass du dein gewinn anonym annehmen
darfst immer gesagt aus welcher region
der gewinner kommt manche menschen
können zwei und zwei zusammenzählen und
werden es bemerken wenn du eine woche
nach dem lotto jackpot mit einem
nagelneuen sportwagen rumpf erst der
andere grund ist aber vielleicht noch
wichtiger man braucht zeit um sich an
den gedanken zu gewöhnen millionär zu
sein denk in ruhe über alles nach und
versucht für dich herauszufinden was
sich wirklich glücklich macht was du tun
möchtest du musst nie wieder in deinem
leben arbeiten aber den ganzen tag in
einer villa zu hocken fernsehen zu
gucken und playstation zu spielen macht
nicht jahrzehntelang spaß
du hast jetzt eine unglaubliche freiheit
und damit auch den fluch dass du für
dein eigenes glück verantwortlich bist
jim carrey hat mal gesagt ich wünsche
mir dass jeder mensch reich und berühmt
wird damit sie sehen können dass es
nicht die antwort ist eine studie zum
thema glück aus dem jahr 1978 hat 22
lottogewinner mit 29 menschen verglichen
die bei einem unfall gelernt wurden
wie zu erwarten sind sie die
lotteriegewinner zu beginn sehr viel
glücklicher als die kontrollgruppe
während die gelähmten menschen
unglücklicher waren doch schon nach nur
einem jahr haben sich beide gruppen
wieder der kontrollgruppe angenähert
die
empfanden möglichkeiten in ihrer neuen
situation spaß zu haben und die
lottogewinner gewöhnten sich stück für
stück an ihr geld und auch wenn man die
studie wegen ihrer kleinen
stichprobengröße nicht als
wissenschaftlichen fakten sehen sollte
hilft sie doch zu versinnbildlichen dass
geld allein nicht glücklich macht
wer jetzt genau nachgerechnet hat dem
wird aufgefallen sein dass noch 10
prozent des gewinns übrig sind diese
zehn millionen darfst du auf den kopf
hauen kaufte ein geiles auto ein boot
eine villa spendet das geld baut ihr
eine firma auf egal was du machst hab
spaß dabei wenn du hast immerhin im
lotto gewonnen
okay das ist natürlich nur ein
spannendes gedankenspiel
machen wir uns nichts vor lotto ist
letztendlich glücksspiel und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass jemand von euch
im lotto gewinnt ist verschwindend
gering
der letzte euro jackpot hatte eine
gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit von 1 295
millionen zusätzlich kein glücksspiel
süchtig machen und hat schon viele
existenzen zerstört die meisten gewinner
spielen wöchentlich und das schon
jahrelang hättest du den letzten 20
jahren jede woche einen lottoschein
gekauft dann läge die wahrscheinlichkeit
in diesen 20 jahren einmal den jackpot
zu knacken immer noch bei grob 1 zu
200.000 gleichzeitig hast du in diesen
20 jahren aber über 11.000 euro im lotto
scheine gesteckt ein klares
verlustgeschäft anstatt also wöchentlich
zwölf euro für lotto auszugeben wäre es
für dich um deine zukunft besser das
geld anzulegen wenn du in diesen letzten
20 jahren jeden monat das geld der vier
lotto scheine also 48 euro investiert
hättest dann hättest du jetzt knapp
30.000 euro hier hast du auch nur 11.000
euro investiert der rest kommt durch die
zinsen dann anlagen ihr seht also
glücksspiel lohnt sich nicht wirklich
wir werden mit dem großen geld geködert
gewinnen werdet ihr aber mit
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit nichts
wenn ihr unbedingt geld ausgeben wollt
dann gibt es bitte nicht organisationen
die die spielsucht von menschen
ausnutzen sondern spendet es an
wohltätige zwecke oder unterstützen
beispiel inhalte die er gerne auf
youtube.com doktor watson hat ganz
zufällig petri an account und wenn ihr
da drei dollar monat zum beispiel
spendet dann werdet ihr unten bei den
videos im abspann genannt und ab 10
dollar
könnt ihr schon die videos früher gucken
vor allen anderen link dazu ist unten in
der video beschreibung wie immer vielen
dank fürs zuschauern und bleibt
neugierig
ich habe gewonnen ich habe gewonnen ich
kündige ist eine firma